poser une question à garder ton chat par
malheur ce que tu me plais qu'est ce qui
se passe monsieur qui s'il vous plaît
attendez attendez prenez prenez un micro
comprend rien au fait qu'est ce qui se
passe encore là dans le public on a en
direct oui quel est votre prénom
quel est votre prénom andreas andres
qu'est-ce qui se passe ce que je vous
vois vous agitez depuis tout à l'heure
dans le public parce que je me bouge et
bastien alors quoi
anthony monsieur allik qui luttent pour
v serge pas quoi là patrick besnier
d'illuminer oui oui qu'est-ce qu'il a
fait un salut nazi
il a fait une quenelle ref vérifier les
images diminue encore pendant que jim et
moi avec qui a vu il indiqué à vue
imposée merci merci merci
il a fait une quenelle à ce que à ce qu
à ce moment là on accepte sur le plateau
je vais c'est comme ça s'il vous plaît
jamais honte mais les outrancier comme
un non mais là est monsieur pays alors
pas ça on fait pas ça ici c'est
inadmissible dans les geôles du jura on
vous êtes été sonné aux élucubrations
depuis tout à l'heure
là franchement si c'est tous les jours
de faire des choses comme ça sur le
gâteau vous pouvez cliquer pas prenez
vos affaires et quitté le plateau merci
monsieur payer ma mère souffrait voilà
merci
merci merci merci merci merci merci s'il
vous plaît merci aller vers celle
observée des ministres allez merci
monsieur bellion garon respectent les
distances de sécurité merci monsieur
bélier voilà ça c'est n'importe quoi
vraiment on veut passer sur les plateaux
on a écouté vos histoires on a été
vraiment en plus compréhensif on a
essayé même de d'essayer de défendre
l'indéfendable
mais là monsieur inadmissible du
pianiste jeune âge qu'on connaît ah oui
bas de la récession comme un oui mais on
on est fier des batteries c'est tout le
monde ici je sais lettres des riverains
merci monsieur ryad en algérie mais
c'est là une missive qui a ouvert ici
j'aime portante pas parce qu'il vient de
se passer
oui en allemagne il ya un mouvement qui
est massif anti masques et iphone et
manifs et h et à 10 km une personne
douce à l'extrême droite
de qui exactement composerez avant d'une
extrême droite le mouvement a évité un
vrai
donc moi je ne voudrais pas que vous
nous laisser penser ce soir à travers ce
geste qui est inacceptable
vous avez un lien idéologique ou de
penser là ça joue pas pour ces jeunes
d'extrême droite en allemagne qui sont
dans la rue et qui font qu'ils prennent
le masque comme un objet d'analysé de
contestation lui alors qu en réalité un
c'est bien plus profond que ça bien sûr
je sens mais là il s'est décrit
jeudi
[Applaudissements]
on a par nature et panique il avoue les
mêmes merci monsieur dans le public et
lui ben complètement l'opulent vers le
haut c'est également voilà qui fait
partie aussi de l'extrême droite
voilà ça sur les plateaux on n'en veut
pas on est là pour discuter pour essayer
de faire avancer
mine de rien le débat est aujourd'hui on
est on est vraiment ça c'est maintenant
voilà ça typiquement voilà il ne s'est
rien passé les adversaires